hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's we're starting in the night for
and I know that things are gonna get bad
so I decided to wear my flannel protect
me at all I'm still gonna die over and
over and over I'm the face of Freddy
fazbear's beats for me I don't care
alright where the hell is he because I
don't know if he was wandering around
while I was doing that I know there's a
way you can't start this early I knows
that for but I don't appreciate oh god
I'm dead aren't I I'm dead I'm dead or
than dead I'm dead Oh times infinity
oh hey nope
[ __ ] god damn I knew I was dead I saw
him whipping by by whatever kind of
slick I was trying not to interrupt the
phone call with the static of the
cameras okay guys I got this okay so now
the phone calls not gonna be there I can
actually keep an eye on it I can find
where he is before it starts moving
around like I don't know why I bothered
to put the camera down at all and check
me where the [ __ ] is he where did he go
where is he whoa - see son where is he
is he here am I not seeing him
something's wrong oh god something's
wrong oh god he's farther along isn't he
oh god where is he
where the hell is he how could he just
disappear I cannot be there
how can he not be where he's supposed to
be did I hear oh god am i missing some
like van ques
wasn't gonna love that whoa damn it oh
damn all of them I didn't mean to you as
long as I can get through this night
I'll be totally fine but I need no worry
frickin is because I haven't seen him
yet I don't know if I saw something out
the corner Mike come on god damn it you
son of a [ __ ] hey Freddie don't be
wandering by there I don't have time for
you oh no no no Blue Boy no damn it
you're all sons of [ __ ] I'm gonna try
to imagine night I don't much appreciate
it because I'm a calm individual if
there's one thing that describes Margot
alarm it's calm and collected in the
face of a device think I see him I think
he was in that one so if I go over there
you might have just moved and I might
have just missed him I don't know but oh
vent vent vent where where where where
where where where where where where is
that you ghost
let's do closed
like doesn't register my DoubleClick's
her vice Basset click it doesn't work my
heart is beating out of my chest it's
not a good life to live when you have a
pathological fear of mannequins and the
tropics you play a game filled with that
such thing that is fear maybe he's like
starting out farther along in a random
location he's not actually far away from
me oh I see him he's right there I got
you but I did wrong stop it don't move
don't move bro don't move
I got you just wait wait yes I'm a
winner I'm a winner for chicken and
dinner or something like that I don't
know the reference is what I know oh
there he is I see him I see his alarm ok
I see what I see I see I see
I like flip to the cam like I noticed
that when I got chica before she goes in
that one room that I just let him into
tres just wandering this final lap so
he's got to be he's got in in our room 7
and there's my damn camera err I'm like
straight up panicking right now and I
wish I wasn't because I'm more calm and
collected than I usually am but
something about this game and a [ __ ]
nosov it I'm still getting used to so
it's none there must be like yeah what
the [ __ ]
oh that's not good I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dad
I'm dad god damn it the [ __ ] puppet
it's gonna be a son of a [ __ ] this is
gonna be a big old son of a [ __ ] how am
I supposed to be that why the hell did
he go in the vent at the exact time -
the puppet decide to show his ugly face
yeah I called you ugly what are you
gonna do about it
pretty pretty okay they're using that
one so okay I must like just barely be
missing him in all these I need to
remember where to look exactly because I
don't I'm screwed and and what the hell
was with the puppets appearing out of
nowhere I don't know why I'm checking I
don't know why I'm checking out of my
camera because frankly this game is all
about the camera and that's great
because that's what I want and the other
ones I felt bad because it wasn't
emphasizing the camera enough okay he's
in that room so I getting back to seven
he'll either go into the vents which is
entirely possible and if he does it
right now I'm gonna be screwed right so
maybe maybe this is where the
pre-emptive thing happens where I need
to make sure that if I lead him into the
room I need to make sure that this game
so if I didn't see him by a balloon boy
that means he's probably by in five by
now or no by five videos
targets quick guys quick he's moving
quick pissing balls how am I supposed to
deal with that oh this is such [ __ ]
such [ __ ] he's in the goddamn fence
but I don't know if it's time seal him
there we go I got him in somehow I got
him in Coley howling [ __ ] I got him in
fortune enough to do that me but okay
look if I have an audio error I should
probably assume that the room he's in
he's probably gonna go into a vent
so that might be a good strategy to just
keep them in place to where I need him
to be hey how's it goin there buddy are
you doing there friend friend friend
friend creepy friends up there you be
okay bye have a good one I have a fun
time somewhere okay so this ventilation
error obviously I don't know what
happens if you like go completely out of
an illusion what kind of system is this
work there's not enough oxygen in this
department such there would be I don't
know I don't even know what I'm saying
right now he's right there getting back
to 6:00
get back to 6:00 I got an audio Arif is
off for some [ __ ] reason fine so long
as everything is fine okay so I'm gonna
preemptively seal this one off just
because because I know he's gonna be
back in that department area so if he
goes into the vents if he won't be able
to go anywhere unless he doesn't go into
events if it's sealed off and they need
to move forward quicker I don't know
what that I don't know what it is I
don't know what it would be but frankly
I don't care as long as I can keep them
controlled before that I see something
out of the corner of my eye if I did I'm
gonna punch him in the face and then in
the big
and then the face and ik and then all
over the body and then straight back to
the dick again I don't know where he's
copying it oh [ __ ] go away Freddie I
don't know where he is
oh there's no I know problems big
problems everywhere conversation with
you at that point
ah [ __ ] two problems of course of course
two problems why not two problems I
probably should have done the
ventilation first because I'm gonna
start with loosen a ting and
everything's gonna go horribly wrong and
I must see edges on my grandma something
like that I don't know why my grandma
don't ask me I'm hallucinating mystery
questions I'm crazy okay let's go [ __ ] I
need to know where he is
this always happens I lose them and then
I can't find him in that's too late and
then it goes somewhere and I can't deal
with it if he's in the vents how about a
be so pissed it's not there up there up
there I must move forward must have
moved forward he's not there it's not
there could he move forward that much
really no way no way he had to be
somewhere that I didn't see him is he
coming here no he's nothing
oh I see you Freddie back there I don't
want to deal with you at the moment
where did he go
oh no no whoa-ho-ho-ho-ho goddamnit
sentence help me
[Applause]
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] I was doing so good and
now I'm [ __ ]
[Applause]
and straight up he's got to be close to
giving it to me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not now
why oh oh you you you you know what I'm
not gonna even gonna be nice you [ __ ]
you and everything you care about or
loved or ever needed in your life I hope
you get nothing beneficial to you to
advance your career I hope you don't get
that promotion don't enjoy all the
lovely things in life I hope you don't
see beaches and travel around the world
I hope you do nothing god damn it I
don't think it's instant death when he's
in that room hallway there I think I can
lead him out if he does get that close I
just I didn't know if I could do that I
was doing so good everything was fine
and then somehow I lost him God if you
guys saw him call me out on it I'm such
an idiot captain no no no no no no no no
no no no no no god damn it no no god
damn it who there
Damon I'm Clark Templar compact and
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ah I saw him get to to get to to get to
to here go go back go back go back come
on I think cam five vent needs to be
done because it's not done then he comes
right to you and that's like the
shortest distance to you so if I can
just keep him away if I can lead him
away then that's gonna be fine I don't
know why anyone will leave him with cam
one that seems like a terrible idea
[ __ ] oh yeah what I've noticed is that
there's like a limited number of times
that you can actually use the audio
before it it'll quit anyway so like
maybe it's strategic to know when it's
going to go out on you and then you can
use it when you need it like if you can
keep them in one place and predictably
know exactly where he's gonna be then
that can aid you in that you know
whatever oh don't don't don't even try
do not
he's not here so you might be oh [ __ ]
god dammit why why why why why who where
no no no no no no no I knew he would
come back to ten I said it and he heard
me and you knew we thought was gonna be
the one weakness yet I hid you probably
moved forward a couple rooms go away
Freddie I don't have time for you I
don't see him there oh no no no no god
dammit
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you God I tried to
flip ah yes please I know I know I know
problems problems problems I've got
nothing but problems what the [ __ ] was
that can't be close enough cannot be
close enough seriously you cannot be
please don't tell me is please don't
tell me in that short span of time that
he somehow managed to get close enough
he did did me where is he did I see him
and miss him
okay he's there so get him back to four
I need to get him back to five as quick
as possible because four there's no
vents five there is a vent yes god
damnit strategy and intelligence wins
I'm strategic and intelligent or
something to that effect I don't really
know if that's the case but hey I did it
oh man that was rough okay I'm rewarded
with one glorious thing oh it's [ __ ] C
both IV oh hey let me see if the numbers
are the same whoa hello shadow Bonnie
why are you there why are you there
that's so weird why is he there I don't
know if I want to follow you but I do
want to explore a bit more because I
know that there's probably stuff in here
that's important I don't know like foxy
wasn't represented in him at all like
was he in in spring-trap I don't
remember foxy being there so it's gonna
be really interesting Hey look cupcake
cupcake right in the middle of the floor
delicious cupcake I think I'm gonna go
for it hooray all my friends are here oh
error my programming won't allow me
foxy - okay so night four has been
beaten and I'm getting a lot better at
the game so hopefully I'll be able to
beat night five without taking too long
because this one only took me 30 minutes
to beat I mean obviously the video was
shorter because you didn't want to see
me flailing around like a ninny the
whole time but either way I'm very eager
to get to the end of this because I know
there's got to be more afterwards and
this guy's gonna be the fifth night but
here we go so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'm gonna get the next
video out very soon and as always I will
see you
[Music]